hi my name is Mohan Joshi I attended the  food is boot camp for pnp with simpler  one of my friend referred me to simply  learn he has attended the last training  provided by them he told me that it's  really good and after attending the  four-day course I to believe that it is  an excellent course and the course  content is very crisp it's properly  aligned to the PMI course infrastructure  and our trainer some it was above  excellence he he gave us real good  training and some of the great examples  I would definitely recommend this goes  to my colleagues and friends as well and  hopefully this course will help me  become a better project manager and I  would pass my PMP exam with flying  colors thank you